how many moves is the longest classical
chess game
i've ever played if you think you know
the answer
send it to ulda at playminers.com
and you can join in our christmas
competition
[Music]
good evening my name is sebastian milov
i'm an employee at play magnus
today i'm here because i can't sleep i
have a severe problems
with magnus 11 bugging me
he's giving me nightmares i can't beat
him
i've been having issues i do not know
what to do
and i've decided it's time
for me to try to take him down on screen
i've noticed that this makes my my my
strength go up significantly and i do
hope it's going to be enough to take
this
this boy down so let's go with 11 and
boom
so we're given the black pieces
yay d4 knight f6 c4 g6 that's what we
want we want to have the king's indian
my favorite opening of all time let's go
e4 d6 you want to close the position
because he's too good in open positions
he's very tricky a very tricky player
he plays this line which is very
interesting very
very critical at high level nowadays
bishop e2 is certainly not the most
common move
bishop g5 queen e8 in order to get to
get rid of the pin
knight d2 i think the right move here is
actually knight
king is actually king h8 and then knight
g8 k
and knight g8 but i'll play knight d7
and knight c5
it's also very logical because what we
want here is to play um
f5 okay so he's clever because if i play
f5 he takes takes he can play bishop h5
and my queen is trapped
so maybe king h89 was correct now and
another problem i have is that if i play
knight c5
he can play b4
so i'll play knight b6
so b3 plays in order to avoid
in order to avoid a4 that's uh that's
okay i'll still play knight c5 though
uh oh it castle's short that's
surprising
play bishop d7 i'm not so worried about
short castling because i'm i'm almost
always under attack in these lines
f3 i'm hoping for f3 if it does that
that's good
okay so he closes down the position he
closes down the position
and i will if i play a 4s bishop g4
so knight c8 so i can improve my knight
a little bit put my knight on d6
and now i'll definitely play a 4. we'll
close down the position that's exactly
what we want
you want to close down the position he
doesn't have so many tick tricks then
that's very good
ok
queen d8 and then b6 simply
we are protecting everything he doesn't
have any breakthroughs on the
the queen side notice that that's very
important
and another thing to notice is that it
doesn't threaten knight xc5 because we
have rookie 8
so we can play g5 queen c3 we can play
h5
we can start attacking now we can play
g4
take 6 knight
e1 queen h4 is looking very good
okay where's the wind guys where is it
rook f6 looks very strong
pretty pretty good thank you
and now i take
the knight g2 and what do i do now
i take on f1
rook f8 check
knight takes e4 i have a very nice
pin right there and rook f2
is that good looks like it
all right so it protects the mate but i
do not think it's going to be enough for
magnus 11.
i don't think it's going to be enough i
think it's gonna lead to a victory
it's gonna lead to a well-deserved
victory
for me king h7
and uh what to do now queen d1
rookie one queen d2
knight b5
maybe it's not so simple
bishop h3
he does have some decent he controls a
lot of squares
bishop takes g2 bishop takes g2 queen e3
check king h1 queen h6 that's mate right
yeah there we go so i did find the win
thankfully i'm very happy i'm very
relieved
that i've finally gotten rid of this
the nightmare is over the nightmare is
over
queen d2 and it's officially going to be
resignation by magnus 11.
we have finally won great stuff
[Music]
you